no upsetting was it when some of the
people that you were caring for started
to get ill and and died devastate and I
did I might respond person I want to go
into palliative care nursing so for me
dignity in death and giving someone an
ending that they deserve is so
importantly having the family with them
making it comfortable and peaceful I
feel like how it happened was it was
just very exciting for me knowing that
their families couldn't be that and some
of them I know at least one of them it
was a shock they have no one with them
it's I'm not I'm not that kind of person
that just cries all the time but I have
days off or I didn't look there but cry
coming out bad just it just laid so
heavy on my heart knowing that that
people were dying without the family and
dying oh the families weren't going to
say goodbye they were going to say
goodbye to the families it was just the
most exciting thing ever been through
more upsetting than losing my own parent
to be honest because I knew that she got
closure she got to see little children
as they are and then I was just with
people's parents who were going on it
tooks I don't think it'll ever leave me
okay red comet
I guess made me up so now I'm thinking
about it I can see people operating for
you and if you like people might mark
this with like PTSD but it works in this
industry while all this has gone on
because it's been I think too certain
I felt guilty of it felt like a bad kids
behold I've not been able I've been
shopping and things like that did I take
it could I have been wrong it's just
yeah it's been the hardest time ever to
me it seems like the home became hospice
overnight and we're not hospice trained
even though I was at home Mother's Day
I've seen dead bodies before I have
never laid on the old and on one day I
laid to out in an hour and nothing could
prepare you for that there's no they
never tell you what to do
or any kind of afterwards there's no
kind of like tea compression or anything
like that when you can talk about you've
been through it back to work and it was
back spurt working with people that we
didn't know if they had coded or not it
was just I don't think I've ever cried
on [ __ ] before but I I cried that day to
me it all highlights a lot understanding
what actually goes on in power homes and
a lack of London because we're just so
short stuff but there wasn't enough time
to say to know what these two people are
just in a room where somebody died let's
give them an hour and you guys take over
it was just we had to keep going on with
it and it's it's different to in a
hospital because I've heard those people
rotary air it be just spent more times
than not done my family and just nothing
nothing can prepare you for the
magnitude of what's going on in those
places at the moment and I hope that
there's some reflection after all the
bits and things are put into ice and
care workers got the respect that they
deserve early